[Musique]
et si l'amour était à réinventer
comment cela se passerait-il si on
remettait tout à plat le modèle
patriarcal est loin derrière nous à sa
suite on a constitué un imbroglio fait
de dans vif à rouge d'aimer mais aussi
de rester libres d'être indépendant on a
donc un grand est de peur de
l'engagement on a manqué un peu de
civisme dans notre manière de nous
quitter on a manqué de poésie dans notre
manière de nous aborder
on a eu beaucoup de déshérence affective
d'isolement on s'est appauvrie mais
c'est normal on repartait d'une feuille
blanche on repartait à zéro
donc on a tout testé mais moi je me suis
dit quand même que c'était pas si normal
de se faire autant mal en amour alors il
ya quinze ans j'ai voulu créer mon
entreprise amoureuse d'accompagnement et
j'ai envie aujourd'hui de vous dire que
l'amour c'est bien plus qu'un seul mot
ses cinq voyages ses cinq voyages et on
a tendance à croire qu'à la fin du
premier
c'est la fin du voyage donc je vais vous
parler de ses cinq voyages qui sont
incontournables dans le bon sens
le premier voyage j'ai voulu raconter à
travers l'histoire de paloma paloma elle
a un frère schizophrène qui est mort il
ya quelques mois
et donc elle a décidé de prendre sa vie
amoureuse en main et de rencontrer
l'amour alors elle fait des rendez-vous
et elle fait des rendez vous surtout en
ne parlant pas des problèmes de sa
famille mais en parlant de ses atouts en
montrant sa confiance en elle en parlant
de ce qui va bien et puis ça marche pas
elle fait des rendez vous elle fait des
petites relations courtes et puis vient
le 31 décembre et le 30 et 31 décembre
peut-être qu'elle boit un verre de trop
mais en tout cas elle rencontre hugo et
hugo hugo il lui plaît pas
spécialement mais elle lui raconte tout
en toute vérité à lui parle de son frère
schizophrène qui est mort ya quatre mois
et qu'elle traverse une phase de sa vie
où elle a en vain fille de s'occuper
d'elle parce que pendant toutes ces
années à la porte et elle a eu d'une
charge sur ses épaules qui a été lourde
avec des policiers qui pouvaient appeler
des ex femme qui voit là elle était en
charge pendant 35 ans est là dans sa vie
elle avait enfin envie comme un papillon
de sortir de sa chrysalide et de
s'ouvrir et ben vous voyez c'est ça le
premier voyage c'est le voyage de l'état
amoureux ou en fait on est dans la
confession
on est dans l'absolu sion on est dans sa
vérité la plus pure la plus juste et
hugo il est tombé amoureux de paloma
pourquoi parce qu'elle s'est livrée avec
une petite musique de l'âme qui est
tellement juste sans aucune cacophonie
et surtout de manière globale elle s'est
tellement confessé sur sa vie elle s'est
livrée sur ces épreuves passées et lui
l'a reçue de manière très juste
et alors lui il a été invité aussi à se
livrer dans sa vulnérabilité comme dans
ses forces et ils sont tombés amoureux
et ça a été le premier voyage alors une
ébullition incroyable des hormones en en
révolution c'est-à-dire tout ce cerveau
qui va mettre en sourdine l'esprit
critique faire en sorte que l'autre est
doué de valeur et que tout le reste de
la forêt on ne voit pas et il voyage
dans ce premier reta amoureux de manière
magnifique et puis quelques mois plus
tard on va rentrer dans le deuxième
voyage le deuxième voyage chez hugo qui
en premier va rentrer dans ce voyage
c'est le doute le doute parce que tout
d'un coup toutes les promesses qu'il
avait faites à paloma ils se demandent
si elles valent encore pour lui en fait
le doute c'est l'époque du discernement
parce qu'avant il avait un certain
prisme de lecture de sa paloma et
maintenant ils rentrent dans une tunnel
où il ne sait plus très bien parce qu'en
fait il a une grande décision à prendre
et quand on a une grande décision à
prendre et bien c'est normal on doute on
se questionne on est dans le noir
on se cogne à droite à gauche alors
voilà c'est le voyage donc numéro 2 qui
est difficile à traverser parce que
paloma qu'est ce qu'elle va avoir comme
réflexe
eh bien elle va vouloir questionner être
assurée et finalement elle comprend que
c'est peut-être la période la plus
fragile de sa relation et que c'est
précisément à ce moment là où il faut
qu'elle prenne un peu de recul elle
aussi qu'elle se pose les bonnes
questions que chacun n'est pas en mesure
en tout cas hugo n'est pas encore en
mesure de rassurer et donc c'est
accouché d'une grande décision qu'est la
décision d mais tel que l'autre et et
alors là on va rentrer dans le troisième
voyage et le troisième voyage c'est la
détox alors pourquoi parce que hugo il a
30 ans il a mis trente ans à se
construire 30 ans à se connaître à
connaître ses valeurs avoir une
connaissance de lui dont il est fier 1
il a un écosystème sur la manière de
voyager de travail est de gérer le sport
de gérer un intérieur mais paloma aussi
qui enfin est libre peut vivre de
manière plus bohème qu'avant peut
profiter de la vie ll a aussi construit
un écosystème un très très logique pour
elle donc chacun a sa logique et le
réflexe du voyage numéro trois c'est de
vouloir amener l'autre dans sa logique
est donc ça donne l'occasion de disputes
de d'issue de secours qu'on peut prendre
pour s'échapper s'isoler ça peut être
les écrans ça peut être le sport à
outrance a peut être l'infidélité
parce que le réflexe premier c'est de
vouloir à montrer à l'autre que notre
logique et saine notre logique est
logique
voilà alors pourquoi ce troisième voyage
il s'appelle la détox parce que sans des
toques son sort jamais du troisième
voyage
paloma et hugo vont partir en week-end
et puis hugo passe devant un magasin un
magasin dhabi où il va s'arrêter et la
paloma est plombée parce qu'elle sait
très bien ce qui va se passer c'est
l'éternel c'est la sempiternelle
elle dispute toujours sur le même sujet
hugo va aller s'acheter des chemises
toujours plus belle toujours plus
blanches toujours plus cher et il va lui
pourrir son après midi
elle qui voulait aller gambader à la
plage sous le soleil mais elle se dit je
vais pas pourrir le week end et le soir
au restaurant elle va monter sur la
montagne du go pour essayer de
comprendre son histoire parce que c'est
plus possible de disputer
toujours pour la même chose alors paloma
lui demande comment ça se passait quand
il était petit comment il était habillé
quand il était petit pourquoi ces
placards là aujourd'hui explose de
chemises à n'en plus finir de vestes à
n'en plus finir de pantalons de tous
pareils et hugo lui explique quand il
était petit il vivait dans les dom et sa
mère étaient d'une conditions difficiles
elle l'avait inscrit dans une école
privée et elle voulait que ça soit lugos
très bien habillé le petit garçon le
mieux habillé de la cour de l'école
sauf qu'elle n'avait pas les goûts du go
elle lui mettais des chemises à jabot et
des pantalons courts et donc hugo
il était sous l'arbre dans la cour et il
est se sentait victime
il se sentait pas intégrer il sentait
malheureux et quand paloma a compris
d'histoire du go en fait est le lien qui
faisait aujourd'hui avec cette volonté
de de faire oublier ce passé douloureux
de s'autoriser en fait à être celui
qu'il a toujours voulu être est bien
plus jamais elle ne pourra réagir de la
même manière quant à nouveau il pourra
peut-être de manière un peu frénétique
vouloir s'acheter la 101e chemise
blanche qui déborde de son placard et là
des docks sont là fait aussi de l'autre
côté c'est à dire que c'est resté
extrêmement curieux quand on est agacé
soi même par l'autre c'est qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe c'est qu'il
ya quelque chose qu'on ne s'autorise pas
que l'autre s'autorise pourquoi c'est
parce que dans son enfance dans mon
enfant je me suis j'ai peut-être une
certaine partie de moi congelés et donc
vous voyez cette détox ce n'est pas
vouloir concédé ce n'est pas vouloir
s'adapter à l'autre ce n'est pas vouloir
s'oublier c'est juste vouloir étendre
étendre ses couleurs et si je vous
prends l'exemple de paloma qui elle veut
toujours
à sortir vivre à plein de surtout ne pas
s'occuper de tout ce qui est logistique
et organisationnel et bien hugo au lieu
de s'agacer il comprend son histoire il
comprend ses 35 années à porter une
charge lourde et que maintenant elle a
du temps à rattraper et en comprenant
son histoire bien finalement il se dit
que peut-être que lui il a aussi un peu
de bohème à prendre en lui parce que
dans son histoire
il a été très figé et donc finalement
c'est ça la mission de l'amour voyez la
mission de l'amour c'est ça c'est ne pas
s'adapter c'est pas faire des compromis
c'est s'élargir c'est reprendre toutes
ses couleurs
et alors quand on en est là alors on
rentre dans le quatrième voyage et
quatrième voyage c'est le voyage de la
connexion parce qu'on est peut-être
quelques enfants plus tard hugo et
paloma sont en famille il faut garder
les connexions c'est à dire que on va
pas remettre à chaque fois en doute son
coupe des cons dispute on s'engage on ne
sait ici et maintenant
la résolution des problèmes c'est pas
d'issue de secours et les 4 connexions
c'est remettre la sexualité au centre
c'est la première connexion vous voyez
comme une chaise
le couple solide selleck quatre piliers
de la chaise la deuxième connexion sais
c'est la spiritualité c'est la connexion
spirituelle c'est à dire paloma va
parler de ses valeurs de ce qu'il anime
de son projet de la troisième connexion
c'est la connexion intellectuelle c'est
rétablir un dialogue sympathique où on
peut échanger librement bon avoir des
moments complices et la dernière
connexion c'est là peut-être la plus
importante c'est la connexion
émotionnelle
parce que la connexion émotionnelle
c'est celle qui vous faire voyager dans
le voyage numéro un qui vous remet
l'état amoureux tout le temps parce que
vous vous connectez à la vulnérabilité
et à la sensibilité de l'autre vous
comprenez où il en est qu'est-ce qu'ils
traversent
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pour lui
aujourd'hui et pourquoi il est chiffonné
vous comprenez qu'est ce qu'il est en
train de traverser et
donc c'est ça la connexion émotionnelle
c'est remettre la confession
l'absolution pour que l'on comprenne
tellement ce qu'il est en train de
traverser ce qu'elle est en train de
traverser alors c'est peut-être pas tous
les jours c'est peut-être juste une fois
par semaine mais s'est reconnecté
reconnecter tout le temps pour remettre
de l'état amoureux dans ce magnifique
voyage qu'est le quatrième voyage est
alors quand on a bien pris ses réflexes
là on rentre dans le cinquième voyage
est le cinquième voyage c'est le voyage
personnel c'est le voyage où finalement
on a créé un tel terreau de confiance
que on a un espace cerveau disponible
on a plus d'atermoiements on a plus de
questionnements de doutes on est quand
même assez bien assis avec une confiance
profonde avec un amour très énergisant
et donc ce voyage basse et loyal
personnel parce que c'est là où on peut
exploser grandir franchir toutes les
montagnes et la hugo va dire à paloma tu
devrais peut-être quitter enfin la
société et monter ta propre structure
parce que tu vois je vais t'aider je
vais te mettre en confiance et parce
qu'elle a l'amour parce qu'elle a cette
confiance inébranlable
alors elle va pouvoir franchir des
montagnes et ça va être la même chose
avec hugo donc vous voyez ses cinq
voyages et bien ce sont des voyages qui
nous enseigne que nous sommes des êtres
de liens moi ce qui me passionne dans
mon métier c'est finalement de dire que
la connaissance de soi comme ça comme
une tour figé je la trouve pas très
intéressante et à paul ricoeur qui nous
dit que le plus court chemin de soi à
soi passe par l'autre pourquoi ne parce
que finalement vous voyez bien que à
travers ses voyages
c'est l'autre qui nous transforme c'est
l'autre qui nous élargi c'est l'autre
qui nous permet presque de panser nos
blessures
c'est comme un psy imaginaire entre nous
c'est ça cette mission de l'amour
alors pourquoi l'amour est à réinventer
parce que ces dernières années on s'est
fait trop mal on a tâtonné
on a tout essayé on a essayé de de ré
inventer des choses mais on n'est pas
arrivé très très loin heureusement on a
quand même progressé on a progressé
parce que il ya eu mitu et les autres
parce que ces derniers mois on a encore
eu des chocs qui nous amène à des fortes
prises de conscience et moi j'ai le
sentiment qu'on est sur un point de
bascule en ce moment c'est à dire
jusqu'à peu de temps j'avais le
sentiment d'être un peu vous savez 7
nicolas hulot d'il ya quarante ans de
tirer les sonnettes d'alarmé on en met à
attention feu partout qu'est ce qui se
passe on se fait trop mal on s'isole on
s'appauvrit
une des premières causes de la
dépression mais celle isolement affectif
alors je pense cependant que ces
derniers temps on est en train de
basculer et pourquoi on est en train de
basculer
parce que on a une telle prise de
conscience qui a été fait avec tous ces
événements terribles qu'on comprend que
on n'est qu'au engagés on est
coresponsable pour co construire une
relation et cette prise de conscience je
trouve qu'elle est toute nouvelle
c'est comme si on sortait de saint tin
broglio et qu'on allait rentrer dans un
amour plus écologique
un amour ou en fait on comprend que ce
terreau ultra fertile et bien ils
demandent de traverser ces voyages et
pour vraiment réinventer un modèle parce
qu'il était temps qu'on tue sept anciens
modèles eh bien je crois que c'est
surtout aux femmes qui est un progrès à
faire
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi parce
que nous les femmes on l'a acquis cette
liberté on n'en est pas loin
franchement on se sent puissante quand
même mais les hommes ont les envahit de
nos attentes qui peuvent être assez
embarrassante
vous savez ces attentes ou ont dit soit
fort j'ai envie que tu admires et ça
c'est une posture qui peut être
épuisante pour les hommes
et c'est cette posture qui parfois leur
amène les amène à leur dire mais de
l'ère de la distance alors qu'en fait si
vraiment on veut être sur un pied
d'égalité
alors il faut savoir dire je vais
t'aimer aussi dans sa vulnérabilité est
ta sensibilité et on a tous les deux à y
gagner
pourquoi parce que l'amour c'est une
émotion et que l'émotion elle ne passe
que par la lumière et la lumière c'est
la sensibilité de l'autre et donc si on
va pas la chercher
et bien finalement elle ne nous touche
pas donc à vouloir de l'admiration à
vouloir des forces et ben finalement
l'autre c'est comme si on lui demandait
d'être aimé pour ce qu'il fait et non
pas pour ce qu'il est quelle catastrophe
quel plus beau cadeau à faire à un homme
que de lui dire je t'aime pour ce que tu
es profondément et non pas pour ce que
tu m'apportes pour ce que tu fais ou
parce que je t'admire ou parce que c'est
incroyable des compétences alors moi je
crois que si on avait un nouveau modèle
à réinventer ça serait celui ci ça
serait un modèle où on serait sur un
pied d'égalité un vrai pied d'égalité où
je te monte mes forces et où je te
montre aussi ma vulnérabilité et ma
sensibilité
pour moi c'est ça l'amour de demain et
ça sera ça le plus grand progrès l'amour
est à réinventer c'est une jolie phrase
de rimbaud et je crois qu'elle est vraie
elle fait vraiment sens aujourd'hui et
que tout le monde a sa place en amour
l'homme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]